[موسيقى]
رقص السباحة هو ذكرى
خلق العالم
[موسيقى]
من الصعب الخاصة كريستي عقد نيزك
والأول هو أن نقول عن التدريس
الدول الأمريكية
الرسمي هو استثناء جديد
راقب
[موسيقى]
الرقص
حسنًا ، إنه من ألفي عصر ما قبل الإسبان
ثلاثة آلاف سنة قبل وصول
وقد تم الحفاظ على الإسبان باسم
هو ولم يرغب في التغيير
ويصبح حفل ​​مايا أ
قبل يوم من الاحتفال بالجسد
لقد تم الحفاظ عليه أنه ينبغي أن يكون
ازياء أصلية جلود أصلية
بعض الأقنعة بشكل جيد
12 حرفيًا يمكنهم القيام به
الأقنعة
[موسيقى]
زائد
قريبا سيكون رقصة الغزلان a
تقريبا الناي خاص جدا.
40 سم طويلة مثل سمك
مرات بوصة في القطر و
الإيقاع التقليدي ما هو الطبل
مصنوع حصريًا من الخشب
مثل هذا يمنحهم
نعمة الحياة من اعمالك
تزرع كذبيحة
هو التواصل من خلال الرقص
هناك اتصال بين الناس و
الأجداد والكائنات الإلهية
[موسيقى]
خاصة أن البلدة بأكملها خرجت لرؤيتها
كل هذا ثم يأتي السياح
المواطنين والأجانب يأتون
[موسيقى]
حسناً بالنسبة لي إنه مقدس إنه عميق
يكررنا باستمرار
وجود الأجداد بيننا
[موسيقى]